all helmets are not equal and we want to
provide an independent way for consumers
to see what's helmets perform better
than others in football when a player
has a head impact the helmets impacted
the skulls impacted and the acceleration
moves the skull and the brain from its
inertial mass lags behind that lag
causes concussion the ongoing question
is how much is too much
everybody gets hit in the head but what
we need to understand is what's the
threshold when there's a long-term risk
this is where we test helmets to try to
give consumers a better idea what
ailments to reduce their risk of
concussions in the mid-2000s we got a
call from our equipment group asking
which helmet to buy we basically found
there's no information publicly
available over the next 12 years we've
collected almost two million data points
every single head impact and practice of
games we took all that data and we
mapped it to a laboratory experiment in
the lab we buy a helmet we test at 120
different times we tested five different
energy levels so one foot two three four
five foot drops
we tested four different directions
front side back and top what we found in
our testing is that the difference in
these helmets is dramatic some helmets
do a much better job at reducing head
acceleration than others we found that
switching from a one start of five-star
helmet reduces your concussion risk in
half for the same impact a one-star
helmet will give you 150 G's 150 times
acceleration of gravity
if you switch out a five-star helmet you
can cut that in half to 75 G's then once
our how much are smaller with generally
one type of padding the five-star
helmets are larger with more complex and
thicker padding structures we first came
out the star system some companies
didn't agree with our methodology now
basically you have an every manufacturer
making five star helmets because
consumers understand the difference
every sport there's a risk of injury you
just have to do the best you can to
reduce that risk how much we're not
going to solve anything you have to
understand that but the difference
between the worst and the best is
dramatic
and so we want you to know if you're a
parent we want your kid to know that
they're playing the best equipment
possible